hello and welcome to this video playing
bones Quinn vasta Franco it's good let's
see what he's up to two wins two losses
to draw so it was as equal mm-hmm ready
Quincy eight
I wonder if III is good here he might
take on c3 is the thing little bit
unsure about this I don't know if I can
I g2r and Bishop age 3 becomes an option
huh maybe I should've played something
different my g2 doesn't look all that
great yeah this is of course also coming
into consideration and I made a mistake
i was thinking d3 here but he can take
on c4 of course okay so v 7s hanging you
cannot just plain I'd see form check yes
this one so if I now okay probably here
which is in the temple I can I don't
know but 95 you probably will play
anyway he did
you didn't ok I can take on b7 now not
sure how good it is but its move
what are we at position
the arab chicks be sound it's an idea
now yeah I don't know can take on c4
maybe on on this the bishop maybe just
place bishops insects
yeah maybe Bishop c6 is good
yeah what a strange game
93 and everything with a strange game I
can take this and I cannot go Queen a
for something like that Jan to see what
Bishop looks totally ridiculous night
a4e goes Crete eggs with the Queen i
guess i can take g to quincy six as well
hmm
yeah I was also thinking would be five
but i take c 6 and then queen f3 takes
takes night c 1 i'm not even trapping
that bloody night okay i have to play
move otherwise I'll lose on time
maybe we'll just take now choose C 402
okay check I have check here and Knight
f3 queen of 391 that's not good okay
let's do it am I know that my exchange
is hanging but I'm not so sure about the
situation after that it's I have Queen
a4 yes to move the king it is not
entirely clear I can pre move this this
one here's the check Andrew p5 check
hope to see cover the noid
can't talk about wacky chess I might win
the noid okay so it's got chicks coming
over here now you got Quincy to check
then I have a pretty badly coordinated
put I'm morning that's really the case
Queen age three may be coming I have
roped is six no this is not a move not
root is six want to keep the pin on the
fifth rank
a bishop 1 C 1 is the worst piece ever
really is I've got time time time and
then then he goes you for checked.check
shoot ah come on i blundered this game I
hate it I really hate it he blunders a
full-piece they are basically and i
blundered back okay white resigns ah
yeah whatever may just blundered a
full-piece step 9 f 2 doesn't work at
all captain so yeah it's it's a little
bit it's a little bit uncoordinated but
they based on this is really bad piece
and I who have one on that mean probably
many ways to win it yeah after age for
it already gets tricky so that the
engine gives this month but this is not
easy for you and you know I mean you're
giving this up because you get it back
with with winning but hmm yeah it's not
an easy move for you and play and I
don't really know what else down a
choice already a little bit of awkward
yeah I have I have no coordination here
it is probably from here the easiest
already was rook f1 and then just get
the King to g1 and this this is really I
mean this is easy actually if it gets to
that this is easy now it's good it's
good coordination I've got every
think covered and he's got problems here
as well yeah awful yeah the whole game
was sort of course a bit strange and
maybe this is a bad decision that's very
likely the engine wants to play that
note that i mentioned i wasn't sure
about this structurally this is terrible
maybe computer likes us but i think the
way he played or system was quite
interesting this it took a very long
time there but should just play whoop
you wouldn't be done with it check okay
so yeah maybe this was an original
intention but this is definitely not a
problem check some something like that
is playable I mean I have a pawn for the
exchange I have this move and he has got
no coordination here so the engine gives
equal or something like that slight edge
for white this is some chance just
blundering yeah if you don't win if your
opponent blunders a piece it's your own
fault thanks for watching